بين حريه التعبير وحجم المحتوى المتطرف
يحتاج مالك تويتر جديد في قراراته الان
الى الماس وضمن قراراته الجديده اقر سياسه
جديده فيما يخص تعليق الحسابات
يحتار اذا مالك تويتر الجديد فبموجب
القرار الذي سيبدا في فبراير تفتح منصه
تويتر الباب امام مستخدميها للطعن على
تعليق حسابهم على الموقع ليتم تقييمها من
اجل اعاده تفعيل الحساب اوضحت شركه انه لن
يتم التعليق الحسابات على المنصه الا في
حاله انتهاكات الجسيمه او المستمره
والمتكرره فالانتهاكات الجسيمه التي تحدثت
عنها المنصه تشمل الانخراط في محتوى او
نشاط غير قانوني وتحريض او التهديد بالعنف
او الاذى والمشاركه في المضايقات التي
تستهدفه مستخد منها اخرين وغير ذلك
اجراءات اقل حده هكذا وصفت تويتر السياسه
الجديده المتعلقه بالتجاوزات على الموقع
من ضمن الاجراءات الجديده سيتم قبل حظر
الحساب الحد من وصول التغريدات التي
تنتهكوا سياسه منصه او مطالبه المستخدمين
بازاله هذه التغريدات قبل الاستمرار في
استخدام الحساب موضوع تعليق الحسابات او
حتى فكه وحضرها دائما ما يحايره ملكه
تويتر الجديد الى مصر الذي تعهد ان يكون
الموقع منبر للحريه لكنه ايضا يواجه
اتهامات بانه سيمنحو المتطرفين والاراء
العنصريه مساحه اكبر على تويتر فهذه
الخطوه تاتي بعد تعرض مصر لانتقادات بسبب
تعليقه حسابات العديد من الصحفيين بسبب
الجدل حول نشري بيانات عامه بشان طائرته
الخاصه لكنه اعاده تفعيل الحسابات في وقت
لاحق ايضا تاتي هذا رفع الحظر عن حساب
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب بعد
اجراء استطلاع راي ايد فيه المستخدمون هذه
الخطوه بفارق ضئين وخلال الشهر الجاري
قعدت وتر تفعيله
10.000 من الحسابات الموقوفه التي تعود
ملكيه بعضها لاصحاب نظريات المؤامره او
اليمين المتطرف
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من الكويت هولندا بنجم
المستشار في امل والتكنولوجيا المعلومات
والتحول رقمي اهلا بك يا رولا ومعنا من
جديد صباح العربيه ابتداءا من اول فبراير
بامكان مستخدم تويتر الطعن على قرار تويتر
لتعليق حساباتهم ماذا اهميه ذلك
الموضوع كثير وخاصه بعض الاجراءات اللي
اخذ بطرد عدد كثير كبير من الموظفين وخلى
الموضوع ايقاف الحسابات يكون اكثر
اوتوماتيك لانه هذا الموضوع بخلي انه ممكن
كثير حساباتي يتوقف بشكل ثبات لك غير صح
او لا اسباب غير صحيحه فهذا الموضوع
بخليهم اذا بدك في المحل معين يرجع يقدمه
بس في ملاحظه كانت بتقدير عندكم
بسبب انه بيعتبر
ما يخلي هذا المحتوى يوصل وهذا الموضوع
تم استخدامها بشكل السلبي
ما يخلي المحتوى يوصل يعني انا ممكن اطلع
تغريده ممكن يكون عندي مليون متابع وما
توصل له من التغريده فهذا الموضوع بيقدر
يخلي الو ماسك يتحكم اي نوع محتوى يصل الى
اجراء جديد
شروط تويتر سيخفي محتواه او كذلك الحد من
وصول التغريدات او مطالبات المستخدم
بازاله التغريده قبل ان يقوم بالتعليق
الحساب كيف رايتهم هذه الاجراءات ههه
اذا بدك همم اذا هو مضبوط بده يحط
المعايير العادي يتحكم بهذا الموضوع
يتحكم بهذا الموضوع السياسيه انه اعلم ان
هو معه ثلاث سياسه معين ضد طلب سياسه ثاني
بامريكا مثلا يعني هم جمهوريين ضد
الديمقراطيسين
السياسيه لاسباب العلاقه بالبسنس بخير
ممكن يكون عم بيحجب محتوياتهن كده حدا يلي
بيعارضه نفس الوقت تكون عم بيوصل المحتوى
للعالمين طيب هل ممكن يكون فيه محاكمات
مستقبليه تخصي تويتر يعني مثلا شرطه
توتريه تحيل ملف قضيه ما الى التحقيق
اكيد مش بهذه الطريقه
من المعالجت الموضوع زعلنا اوتوماتيك
سيستم هي اللي هو الخوارزميات تابعون اذا
اخذوا قرار بحاجه حساب ما بيستاهل الحجر
يقدر يتدخل الاشخاص الموظفين طيب
بدي بس اناقش معك الانتهاكات يحددها تشمل
انتهاكات المشاركه في مضايقات تستهدف
مستخدمين الاخرين وهذا مفهوم الثانيه
التحريض او التهديد بالعنف والاذى هذا
المفهوم لكن الانخراط في محتوى او نشاط
غير قانوني مين اللي يحدد المحتوى الغير
القانون في هذه الحاله
تحديدا هذا السؤال الاهم نحن في عندنا
نقطتين بيحددوا مين هو المحتوى الغير
قانوني اول شيء لانه تويتر هو منصه تاب
على امريكا فبيخضع للاوانين الامريكيين
مثلا اي مواضيع ما مصدومه مسلفتها مساء
امريكا
هذا الموضوع
هذا الموضوع موجود على فيسبوك وانستغرام
سابقا انه انت في محتوى بشدولك اياه او
بيحذفوا لك اياه انت بتعمل انه انا ايديس
اجري يعني انا بعارض هذا القرار لانه انا
الموضوع اعتبرته انه غير مناسب بس هو
مناسب فبيرجع اشخاص
بيناقشوا الموضوع هن بقلب تويتر ويا باخذه
على قرارك انه لا مضبوط هذا انحذف المحتوى
بالغلط او الحساب بالغلط فهو بياخذه لا
انه المحتوى حضرتك
احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه
المعلومات من الكويت من المستشار في انواع
التكنولوجيا المعلومات شكرا لك